[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité nous débuterons ce
journal avec la Cité internationale de
la langue française inauguré en début de
semaine et nous verrons avec queo TV la
chaîne de la voie du Nord comment le
château de villeercot TR est devenu
l'adresse du
français président du Comité européen
des régions à Bruxelles ce maire de la
Sarte s'est rendu en Ukraine près de la
frontière polonaise à son retour il a
rappelé auprès de LMTV Sart que la
guerre y est toujours aussi violente
vous verrez dans ce journal la décision
a beaucoup agacé les motards mais le
contrôle technique des motos entrera
bien en vigueur en avril 2024 même si
tous les points prévus ne seront pas
contrôlés dès cette date une équipe de
TLC dans la Loire l'a constaté dans un
centre de contrôle technique enfin notre
partenaire tv78 a visité pour nous le
célèbre zoau de toiri qui enrichit son
parcours en proposant lumière sauvage
une magnifique déambulation féérique qui
nous rappelle que Noël
approche mais commençons ce journal avec
ces images impressionnantes de la
tempête carane qui a traversé le qu
nord-ouest de la France durant 48h comme
annoncé par les prévisionnistes des
rafales de vent à plus de 150 kmh et
d'importantes précipitations ont
entraîné de nombreux dégâts sur le
parcours de la tempête comme vous le
voyez sur ces
images 600 Compagnons du Devoir et 65
ororss de métier ont travaillé à
ressusciter le château de Viller côré
laissé à l'abandon durant de nombreuses
années sous l'impulsion d'Emmanuel
Macron l'ancienne résidence royale de
François prier a été réparée après 3 ans
de travaux pour devenir la Cité
internationale de la langue française
pour rouer TV la chaîne de la voie du
Nord gérô on nous fait découvrir ce lieu
où la langue française se donne à voir
et à
entendre le président Emmanuel Macron
inaugurer ce jour la Cité internationale
de la langue française un espace de
23000 m car situé au cœur du château de
Viller côré dans l'aine le chantier
initié en 2017 a mobilisé quelques 220
entreprises pour restaurer ce lieu
chargé d'histoire en 1539 François 1ier
y signait une ordonnance imposant
l'usage de la langue française dans la
rédaction des textes juridiques devant
un parterre de quelques 500 invités
Emmanuel Macron a dessiné ce qui est
désormais le plus important projet
culturel en dehors de Paris ce sera un
lieu pour les enseignants et leurs
élèves pour venir apprendre découvrir
étudier la langue française pour venir
se former également je veux qu'ici les
professeurs avec leur classe puissent
venir découvrir des mots car la France
est une puissance éducative et que
l'ensemble des professeurs français
puissent venir y
apprendre les fondamentaux de ce qu'est
la transmission du français la Cité
internationale de la langue française
c'est un parcours ludique de 15 salles
soit 1200 m Carr dédiés au français et à
disposition de tous les publics outre
les 150 pièces de collection exposées
sur place 62 outils de médiation seront
accessibles pour permettre aux plus
jeunes de s'emparer des mots et de leur
histoire c'est un parcours permanent qui
tout le long du premier étage nous
emmène dans le voyage des mots dans la
migration des mots dans le transport par
les mots les émotions parce que en
français on chante en français on aime
en français on pleure aussi et on
s'aperçoit à quel point notre langue une
langue ce sont les sentiments les plus
intimes et les plus forts qui viennent
nous toucher donc ici quel âge qu'on est
qu'on soit un enfant qu'on soit un
vieillard peu importe on trouvera des
choses à la fois très sérieuses et très
ludiques le site à la fois bibliothèque
salle de spectacle et résidenceces
d'artistes accueillera le Sommet de la
Francophonie en mars
prochain
que ce soit en Ukraine comme vous le
verrez ou au Moyen-Orient la guerre a
malheureusement des conséquences
humanitaires dramatiques mais aussi
économiques Dom Benoît directeur du
magazine géostratégie était à Monaco
pour une conférence et nos équipes ont
recueilli son expertise sur les
conséquences du conflit entre le Hamas
et Israël sur nos économies dans les
territoires en France et en
Europe des conséquences humaines
dramatiques naturellement des
conséquences monétaires le chéquel
israélien a considérablement baissé
depuis le début du conflit Israël est un
pays pour autant très puissant la banque
centrale israélienne dispose d'énormes
réserves de change en dollars 200
milliards de dollars donc il est fort
probable qu'Israël avec un PIB qui plus
est considérable près de 500 milliards
soutiennent sa monnaie quelles vont être
les conséquences sur nos économies ici
en Europe principalement sur l'économie
française de ce conflit alors si je peux
dire très largement semblablement les
mêmes que celle que qui que nous avons
vécu durant les différents conflits
c'est-à-dire l'augmentation du cours du
pétrole
qu'est-ce qu'on trouvera dans
géostratégie magazine ce mois-ci dans
les kiosques alors pour le numéro qui
est en kiosque le dollar est-il fini
avec une couverture avec Jacques de la
rosier l'ancien directeur du FMI on
tente de répondre à la question
évidemment le dollar n'est pas fini le
dollar a de belles années devant lui
représente encore 60 % des réserves de
change des tenu au sein des banques
centrales le 45 % des transactions
l'essentiel pour le marché obligateire
et puis pour le numéro qui va sortir un
dos complet sur le conflit
israelllo-palestinien et également un
point sur l'économie russe l'économie en
Ukraine et les économies occidentale
voilà tout à fait autre chose au Comité
européen des régions qui représente les
élus locaux et régionaux des différents
pays membres de l'Union européenne le
maire de couen dans la Sarte faisait
partie d'une délégation qui s'est rendue
en Ukraine à halvive près de la
frontière polonaise il a pu constater
que la guerre continue de dévaster le
pays il témoigne de ce qu'il a vu là-bas
au micro d'Enzo pour LM TV s
regardez le 16 octobre dernier le maire
de couline Christophe Rouillon se
rendait dans cet hôpital alvive une
ville de l'ouest de l'Ukraine un
déplacement effectué avec d'autres élus
européens pour apporter un soutien
politique mais aussi une aide
humanitaire 10 jours après le maire
sartois reste marqué par ce qu'il a vu
nous voyons des jeunes hommes amputés
des bras jambes des personnes
des femmes des enfants en fauteuil
roulant voilà là c'est humainement les
yeux dans les yeux les conséquences de
de cette guerre
terrible une guerre terrible qui se
raconte aussi loin de la ligne de front
comme dans ce cimetière où 700 soldats
ont été enterrés on voit
passer les cercueils dans des véhicules
et puis derrière les familles les
enfants euh voilà c'est poignant on peut
pas si on peut pas se résigner à cette
banalité de de la guerre ce sont des
jeunes hommes ce sont des étudiants ce
sont des travailleurs des gens qui ont
décidé de de se battre pour leur
patrie et pourtant le pays est résilient
pour Christophe Rouillon il faut
maintenant l'accompagner dans son
processus d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne la perspective de rentrer
dans l'Union européenne est très
importante elle elle donnera un espoir
aux populations elle permettra de
stabiliser le pays de stabiliser le
continent et donc il faut préparer cela
il faut préparer la la reconstruction de
de l'Ukraine mais il faut aussi donner
une architecture juridique à à ce pays
améliorer la démocratie locale lutter
contre la corruption faire émerger des
élites locales qui demain seront là pour
tenir le pays et si l'Ukraine tombe nous
aurons la Russie impérialiste poste
soviétique aux portes de l'Europe avec
Vladimir Poutine qui qui ira plus loin à
son échelle couen a signé un partenariat
avec une ville d'Ukraine pour accueillir
une vingtaine d'enfants lors d'un séjour
en Sarte loin des bombes et de la
guerre à l'approche de l'hiver où la
demande est forte en électricité la
France a souvent besoin d'importer cette
énergie pour faciliter ces échanges 64
km de câble électrique relie la ville de
Santa logaya en Espagne et celle de
bexas dans les Pyrénées Orientales
intégralement souterraine cette
interconnexion en plein cœur des
Pyrénées a coûté plus de 700 millions
d'euros objectif à terme pour l'Union
européenne doubler les capacités
d'interconnexion iici 2035 regardez ce
reportage éclairant d'Isaac Barry pour
VI Occitanie on a à peu près 7 km côté
français 1 km côté espagnol 64 km de
câble électrique rit la ville de Santa
yogaya en Espagne et celle de Bachasse
dans les Pyrénées Orientales
intégralement souterrain cette
interconnexion en plein cœur des
Pyrénées a coûté plus de 700 millions
d'euros l'objectif des interconnexions
c'est d'utiliser euh l'électricité euh
la plus euh la plus intéressante
possible au sens celle qui est le
produite par des moyens de production
les plus propre possible donc on avait
euh jusqu'en 2015 on pouvait échanger
1400 MW euh d'énergie entre la France et
l'Espagne aujourd'hui on peut en en en
échanger 2800 voilà donc c'est à peu
près l'équivalent de trois réacteurs
nucléaires hein mais le courant ne sera
pas directement envoyé dans les ménages
elle doit d'abord passer dans une
station de conversion comme ici à
bachass si on est dans un moment où on
importe de l'électricité depuis
l'Espagne on va donc impor on va avoir
du
courant continu qui va arriver ici qu'on
va transformer en courant alternatif et
qui va ensuite partir sur notre réseau
pour alimenter des clients français et
puis si on est dans un moment où on a
plutôt à exporter de l'électricité vers
l'Espagne et bien à ce moment-là c'est
notre courant alternatif qui être
transformé en courant continu pour
partir dans l'interconnexion à
l'approche de l'hiver où la demande est
forte en électricité la France a souvent
besoin d'importer cette énergie à
l'heure qu'il est on est importateur
c'est-à-dire l'Espagne nous fournit à
peu près 1500 MW d'électricité parce
qu'il y a à ce moment en Espagne des
moyens de production euh éolien ou
solaire par exemple qui sont disponibles
et qui nous permettent de de bénéficier
de cette de cette électricité objectif
pour l'Union européenne doubler les
capacités d' interterconnexion d'ici
2035 contrairement aux idées reçues les
morts se faitent le 2 novembre cette
première semaine de novembre est
l'occasion de se rendre dans les
cimetières bien sûr des cimetières qui
pour certains sont emplis de légendes et
de signes ésotérique Jacques sirgan est
non seulement guide au cimetière du Père
Lachaise mais surtout vampirologue il a
conduit une équipe de 20 minutes TV sur
la tombe d'Honoré de Balzac regardez
donc là on peut voir des marrons sur les
sur la tombe de Balzac tout petit objet
remplit cette fonction sur gazbau à
montparnas les gens mett des tickets de
métro des cigarettes c'est une preuve
d'amour de protection à l'origine rituel
juif on plçait un rocher devant le
tombeau quand les Juifs antérieurement
dans les grottes pour protéger le
tombeau donc c'est un signe de
protection quand on n' pas de rocher ce
qui est lourd et compliqué et grand on
rempasse par un petit caillou mais quand
on a pas petit caillou sous la main on
met un marron voilà et puis repousser
depuis 2014 le contrôle technique des
motos et des scooters entrera bien en
vigueur en avril 2024 malgré les enjeux
de sécurité routière cette mesure reste
peu populaire auprès des motards et de
surcroix encore compliqué à appréhender
par les contrôleurs comme l'a constaté
Anthony verpillon pour TL7 près de
Saint-Étienne regardez et c'est
désormais officiel le contrôle technique
des deux roues entrera en vigueur le 15
avril 2024 le décret est paru au Journal
Officiel le 23 octobre dernier il
imposera donc un contrôle 5 ans après la
mise en circulation d'une moto et même
d'un scooter puis ensuite tous les 3 ans
à partir du premier contrôle une
communication certes mais dont les
modalités sont encore floues comme on a
pu le constater dans ce garage de Roche
la Molière on est en train d'essayer de
chercher les dates de périodicité pour
les contrôles catégorie l qui correspond
trotau de roues et au trois roues car si
on lit le décret les points de contrôle
exacts qui sont à vérifier sur les deux
roues n'apparaissent pas clairement une
info pourtant essentielle pour les
contrôleurs techniques il y a une chose
qui avait été dite on va dire en bruit
de couloir que on aurait uniquement pour
le moment de contrôler le bruit et le
les valeurs de pollution et puis le
reste serait des contrôles visuel après
au niveau du bruit ça assez compliqué
parce qu'en fait sur le sur une carte
grise vous l'avez ici en U1 je perdu il
est là voilà c'est les décibels qui sont
contrôlés en fait en laboratoire sans
bruit externe nous c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui de faire une cabine
insonorisé pour faire des tests
antibruit et eux sont sur leur moto au
quotidien les motards de la brigade
motocycliste urbaine de Saint-Étienne ce
sont eux qui devront s'assurer que les
contrôles techniques ont été faits
indispensables selon ce policier
retrouve davantage de
scooter avec des échappements modifiés
avec des différents éléments de sécurité
les feux les plates qui parfois au fil
des années arrivent à être un peu plus
dégradé et noté que ce sont les deux
roues mis en circulation avant le 1er
janvier 2017 qui seront contrôlés en
priorité à terme c'est-à-dire en 2026
tous les deux roues devront avoir été
contrôlés voilà jeter nos déchets en
l'étriant nous essayons tous de le faire
le plus souvent dans des poubelles en
plastique et avec un choix très limité
Benedict rou ancien salarié d'un
syndicat d'élimination des déchets
ménagers a eu l'idée de développer toute
une gamme de bacs de tri des déchets en
carton en carton donc recyclable Alain
Druot l'a rencontré pour cette
alimoge là c'est vraiment des bacs qui
sont destinés à amener des déchets après
pour être valorisés donc ce ne sera plus
des déchets ce sera valorisé soit à
donner à une assosce ou à de la famille
ou à des amis soit à amener à la
déchetterie VO recycler C aussi l'idée
porté par les Alpes françaises qui ont
décidé de se porter candidate à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques d'hiver en 2030 alors si
la France n'avait plus organisé les Jeux
d'été depuis un siècle elle a organisé
les gos d'hiver en 1924 en 1968 et plus
récemment en 1992 et a su entretenir et
péréniser de nombreuses équipes qu'elle
soit utilisée à nouveau dans une
candidature à l'impact carbone le plus
limité possible les explications avec
lucou pour notre partenaire h
Montblanc l'idée prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur réutiliser d'anciennes
infrastructures olympique en vue d'une
potentielle candidature au Jeux d'hiver
2030 dans cette optique les trempelins
de Courchevel pourrait réaccueillir la
prestigieuse compétition 38 ans après
les épreuves de soaskii des Jeux
Olympiques
d'Alberville très intéressé par cette
perspective la station savoyarde rêve de
raviver la flamme pourquoi aller
reconstruire rebétonner alors que en
fait on on a déjà quelque chose
d'existant qui peut être un amélioré
évidemment puisque on est quand même
dans un équipement de 92 qui que ce soit
sur la partie remontée mécanique ou sur
sur la forme des trempelins a pas
beaucoup bougé donc bien sûr qu'il
faudrait y a des choses à améliorer à
Courchevel ou à La Plagne la réflexion
est la même chacune des stations espère
s'appuyer sur l'héritage des Jos de
1992 pour maximiser ses chances en
service depuis maintenant 30 ans la
piste de bobslake de la PLNE est un
modèle de réussite depuis ces nombreuses
années les équipes de la piste ont su
développer un certain savoir-faire fait
32 ans que la piste olympique de bobsleg
a un modèle économique qui fonctionne
qui permet
à peu près un équilibre budgétaire
chaque saison c'est un des atouts
majeurs comme également d'avoir changé
de système de réfrigération on est passé
de l'ammoniac à l'eau glycolé en 2007
200008 on est aujourd'hui la seule piste
également à avoir fait ce ce ce
changement cette ce cette mutation de
système de réfrigération c'est aussi un
atout sur le territoire en terme
d'attractivité et ça ce sont évidemment
des des arguments qui pèsent enfin à mon
sens qui peuvent peser très lourd dans
la balance de la candidature des travaux
de modernisation seraiit donc seulement
à prévoir sur les deux sites un atout
écologique et surtout économique qui
irait dans le sens de la future
candidature
française développer la fréquentation
touristique en s'appuyant sur une offre
hôtelière diversifiée c'est l'ambition
de la ville de TR connue pour sa
basilique sainturbain la création
récente de l'Hôtel La Licorne valorisée
par CIN étoiles permet d'attirer une
nouvelle clientèle à 3 comme l'explique
Christelle tayarda directrice de
l'agence de développement touristique du
département de l'Aube au micro de notre
partenaire Canal 32 3 a beaucoup de
choses à offrir mais il faut qu'on ait
des premières raisons de venir un 5
étoiles c'est une première raison de
venir la personne qui vient qui veut du
luxe qui fait un spa et qui s'en va
c'est de plus en plus rare il y a aussi
des gens qui veulent profiter de la
pleine nature notamment les clientel
anglsaxon les
Australiens en France 10 % des décès par
noyat sont consécutifs au fait de ne pas
savoir nager l'opération comme un
poisson dans l'eau offre un accès pour
tous aux infrastructures aquatiques ce
qui est un premier pas vers
l'apprentissage de la natation à
saint-diier des vuges Livia bulcheré et
Denis leken ont sauté dans le grand bain
avec les enfants et c'est pour V TV
regardez en soufflant oui en bravoo yes
ils ont entre 6 et 10 ans et parmi eux
certains ne fréquentent la piscine que
de manière exceptionnelle en France plus
d'un enfant sur TR ne sait pas nager
avant à rentrée en 6e l'opération
nationale comme un poisson dans l'eau
existe pour combattre les inégalités et
rendre l'activité accessible à tous
toute la semaine ces 16 enfants
bénéficieront de l'accès au centre
aqualudique Aquanova America à saint-di
desvuges je suis déjà venue l'année
dernière avec bah le centre social et
bah oui j'aime bien nanger c'est trop
bien moi j'aime bien faire de la piscine
je viens souvent avec ma maman mon papa
en famille des fois s'ils savent nager à
la fin de la semaine c'est parfait mais
le but déjà c'est le plaisir de venir
pratiquer c'est vraiment ça l'essence
même de ce qu'on veut sur cette semaine
là leur donner l'accès leur montrer
qu'ici c'est du plaisir et et en même
temps qu'on peut apprendre des choses et
si déjà on arrive à franchir ce cap avec
eux de les faire venir à la piscine on a
déjà une première victoire au total à la
fin des vacances d'automne 32 enfants
des centres sociaux Lucie aurac et
germinetillon auront bénéficié de ce
dispositif financé par la commune en
France 107 piscines participent au
dispositif différent de celui de l'État
le savoir nager avec tout de même des
objectifs qui se rejoignent comme celui
de la prévention des noyades on en parle
jamais assez les noyades ont une une
part vraiment très importante en France
et ailleurs et c'est vrai que si par ce
genre d'action on peut aussi lutter
contre ce phénomène là bah je suis à 100
% preneur les noyades accidentell sont
la première cause de mortalité par
accident de la vie courante chez les
moins de 25 ans le dispositif entend
bien y remédié l'opération qui fait
cette année c'est 10 ans avec pour Maren
à cindier les volayeuses des audaciennes
dont la capitaine Julie molinger avait
déjà permis cet été à 180 enfants des
aodaciens de profiter des
infrastructures enfin nous avons tous
collectionné ces célèbres vignettes de
nos joueurs de foot préférés avec
l'espoir de compléter notre album le
club de basket de Château giron a décidé
de créer son propre album en prenant en
photo chaque joueur du club une solution
qui permet à la fois de diversifier les
sources de financement pour le club et
de créer du lien dans le club comme l'a
constaté TVR à Rennes alors voilà la
maquette qui donc encore effectivement
une maquette puis que c'est pas tout à
fait la taille réelle de la du futur
album l'idée c'était vraiment de trouver
trouver une nouvelle manière de de de de
de communiquer ou de de
proposer quelque chose de différent où
on peut pour le club gagner de l'argent
et pour les adhérents à l'image du club
créer du du lien vraiment entre bah les
tout jeunes l'équipe fagon la détente
savoir qui est qui créer créer du lien
en Martinique Chac n une centaine de
jeunes et formés aux différents métiers
de l'agriculture mais à l'issue de leur
formation 80 % d'entre eux ne trouvent
pas de terre malgré de nombreuses
friches disponibles pour y remédier le
collectif Les formmer sans terre a
organisé la mise en relation de ces
agriculteurs avec des propriétaires
c'est un reportage de François eudoxy
Dayana pour via TV sur
place Audrey rêve de pouvoir développer
son exploitation agricole de plantes
médicinales aujourd'hui elle est en
reconversion professionnelle pour
devenir agricultrice depuis son retour
en Martinique il y a 5 ans avant de
réaliser son projet elle est confrontée
à un problème majeur c'est le manque de
terre qui
est qui est mon mon obstacle premier
puisque je n'ai aucune propriété je ne
suis pas propriété terrienne je je
débute de de0 organisé par le collectif
lesformés centair cet événement a per de
mettre en relation les agriculteurs
formés avec des propriétaires qui
veulent louer ou vendre leurs terrain
chaque année une centaines de jeunes
sont formés au métier d'agriculteur en
Martinique 80 % d'entre eux ne trouvent
pas de terrain pour commencer leur
activité alors que le territoire regorge
de possibilités dit qu'il y a entre 8000
et 10000 hectares de terre en friche ce
sont quelques fois des terrains
agricoles mais qui sont redevenus en
Frich c'est-à-dire on a laissé la forêt
repousser il y a une autre problématique
aussi c'est qu'en Martinique on on est
soumis au problème de l'indivision il y
a énormément de de familles qui ont des
terrains mais les terrains sont
indivisues et ça aussi c'est ça pose
problème quant à laquisition ou la
transmission de terrain à de futurs
agriculurs pour le député Marcelin nado
Parin de l'événement cette problématique
pourrait décourager certains jeunes et
freiner l'objectif de la souveraineté
alimentaire de plus en plus il y a des
jeunes qui comprennent l'intérêt par
exemple d'agriculture biologique il y a
des jeunes qui comprennent l'intérêt de
Prati cultur différent et bien justement
à travers ces actions concrètes soutenu
et accompagné nous pouvons aider les
volontaires les volontaires parmi les
jeunes qui souhaitent à la fois rester
vivre au pays et exercer le métier
d'agricultur le collectif formé centire
devrait poursuivre son action en
rencontrant la CTM et en accompagnant
les agriculteurs et les propriétaires
dans les
procédures à la nuit tombée quand les
animaux du zoau de Toir disparaissent
aux yeux des visiteurs la magie des
lanternes prend place sur un magnifique
parcours où se mêlent différents univers
féériques de grands animaux
emblématiques mais aussi la faune et la
flore de chaque continent de la planète
c'est la 6e édition de cette opération
et il faut souligner que pour réduire
l'impact carbone du festival 75 % des
lumières sont restaurées chaque année
par des équipes d'artisans et réutilisé
vous allez le voir pour tv78 Mélanie
poket et Clara Frutos ont encore les
yeux émerveillés regardez
entrer dans un monde enchanté les
lumières sauvages de Toir sont
installées un parcours d'un peu plus
d'un kmètre à travers les jardins du
château pour voyager au cœur des grands
continents des peuples et de leur
écosystème c'est effet érique c'est
vraiment magique on tombe complètement
en enfance on voit tous ces animaux
c'est c'est vraiment magnifique moi j'ai
bien aimé ça a l'air bien la la nouvelle
partie d'Asie qu'ils ont fait donc on on
va aller découvrir ça je trouve ça
magnifique il y a eu des améliorations
enfin des des changements par rapport
aux années précédentes ils ont ajouté
des scènes de vie avec des personnages
jusqu'au 10 mars 2024 le zoo safari a
choisi d'illuminer les fins de journée
avec une 6e édition de ces lumières
sauvages le thème de cette année l'Asie
un an de travail de réflection pour les
équipes qui proposent une nouveauté un
renouveau avec encore beaucoup plus
d'immersion avec le labyirinth qui est
complètement qui sera complètement
illuminé cette année et puis derrière
vous vous avez l'Asie qui prend vie avec
tous les animaux d'Asie et juste
derrière moi les bouddas aussi les
temples qui vont pouvoir animer cette
scène le parcours est agrémenté de près
de 3000 lanternes 75 % d'entre elles
sont restauré chaque année un souhait du
site il ne vous reste plus qu'à vous
laisser
[Musique]
porter voilà et cette semaine vous
trouverez en kiosque deux éditions
spéciales du point consacré à R et à
Nice elles sont coordonnées par audreé
Emer à reince il sera question des
grands projets de la ville pour 2030
mais aussi des ambitions du maire de la
ville Arnaud Robinet plus au sud les
équipes du point ont enquêté sur les
ambitions de la métropole niissoise
présidée par Christian Estrosi qui veut
prévenir les effets du dérèglement
climatique sans renoncer à son
développement économique et culturel
voilà ces éditions du point sont en
kiosque ce weekend bien sûr voilà et
puis nous par à can nous voulions
absolument saluer Philippe Bouvard qui
fêtait cette semaine à 94 ans ses Noos
de platine 70 ans de vie partagé avec
Colette lui a longtemps été une grosse
tête elle est restée une forte tête
sauvage de son nom de jeune fille ils
étaient fait pour s'entendre même si
l'humour a beaucoup contribué à cette
longévité regardez
undomadaire ne paraît qu'une fois par
semaine un couple lui dispose d'une
périodicité
quotidienne c'est là que les problèmes
commencent parce que c'est c'est c'est
pas toujours très
facile mais bon les auteurs dramatiqu et
les deux couples savent que si l'on veut
éviter le passage de la comédie à la
tragédie il faut ménager quelques
anthractes
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand JT des territoires au
revoir à
[Musique]
tous